North Korea conducted a huge live-fire
military drill this morning the show of
force was part of a birthday celebration
for North Korea's military the drill
happened as the us-south Korea and Japan
started new military exercises the US
aircraft carrier Carl Vinson is moving
closer to South Korea Adriana Diaz is in
Beijing with the escalating showdown
Adriana good morning good morning in
addition to beefing up America's
military presence near North Korea
president Trump is also ramping up his
war of words Monday he said Kim jong-un
is not as strong militarily as he says
and also blamed the international
community for not doing more to rein him
in the status quo in North Korea is also
unacceptable at the White House on
Monday President Trump scolded members
of the UN Security Council for falling
short in their dealings with North Korea
the council must be prepared to impose
additional and stronger sanctions in a
show of force intended to send a warning
to North Korea the USS Carl Vinson
Strike Group along with two Japanese
destroyers are rapidly approaching the
Korean Peninsula there they'll be joined
by South Korean ships the USS Michigan a
nuclear-powered submarine also arrived
in the port city of Busan today
angered by the build-up and the threat
of further sanctions the regime has
stepped up its rhetoric unveiling new
weapons while lashing out at its
adversaries North Korean state media
called the military movements extremely
dangerous saying the US should consider
carefully any catastrophic consequence
this raises the stakes analyst Jonathan
Pollock's as the White House needs to
proceed cautiously with the United
States and others talking far too
loosely about the prospects of a
preemptive strike that's what would
trigger retaliatory actions by North
Korea it's also been three days since
korean-american professor Tony Kim was
detained at Pyongyang Airport Kim joins
two other Americans being held by the
regime we could stumble needlessly into
what would be the biggest crisis in East
Asia since the United States intervened
in the Korean War in 1950 to avoid that
president Trump is working closely with
China he's already spoken to China's
president twice in the past two weeks
tomorrow the full US Senate will be
briefed on North Korea by administration
officials at the White House Alex
Adriana Diaz in Beijing thanks